the bitcoin conference came to miami and
30 000 people came in person and there
was many many more who watched the live
stream ultimately when you see this many
people coming together some could argue
as david bailey did this was the largest
math conference in history but if we
take this seriously for a second we
think about what the takeaways were from
an event like the bitcoin conference
it's pretty clear that not only is there
a lot of enthusiasm energy and momentum
behind bitcoin and the various products
and services that are being built on top
and around it but also what we are
watching is that bitcoin is infiltrating
every aspect of society there was
professional athletes there were
musicians there were companies investors
politicians economic development
individuals all sorts of different
people attending the bitcoin conference
miami has gone as far as literally
putting forward this massive life-size
bull it's mocking the wall street bowl
that sits in new york city and so
ultimately as we continue to see so many
different people working on bitcoin we
are watching bitcoin have an impact on
politics on culture and on finance
bitcoin has become inevitable at this
point we are watching 150 million or
more people hold the asset and the
compound annual growth rate over the
last decade still sits at 150 percent
but what's the most interesting to me
it's not the price it's not about the
investment opportunity it's the fact
that there are thousands of companies
that are building products and services
around bitcoin to help people get into
bitcoin or on top of bitcoin as a
computing network
ultimately bitcoin is the most secure
network in the world and what we saw
over the last week is that people are
innovating around a technology that was
born just 13 years ago by a
pseudo-anonymous founder satoshi
nakamoto and my guess is as we get more
and more people intelligent folks who
are armed with capital we're going to
continue to see more innovation
the bitcoin conference every year is a
bunch of fun to attend i highly suggest
you attend next year but in the meantime
remember you at home us here and there's
millions of people around the world our
job is to continue to build build on top
of bitcoin build for bitcoin and
continue to explain to individuals
why bitcoin is so damn important hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time